typically game devs tried to downplay
shortcomings instead preferring to say
things like didn't work out or we're
winding this down or even with sun
setting this idea so it's rare to see
devs outwardly use the word failure but
that's what's happened with action game
Afro Samurai - Revenge of the koomer the
games been canned and it's being pulled
from sale I'm Dave and welcome to your
GS news update so yes Afro Samurai 2 is
currently being pulled from the
PlayStation Store Xbox Marketplace and
steam but why well in an interview with
cg magazine developer vs. evils general
manager Steve Escalante explained that
this game was a failure and the studio
has canceled voting - and volume 3 and
is issuing refunds to players who
purchased the game he said we could not
do in good conscience volumes 2 & 3 so
we've begun process it's been a long
process to figure out because Sony has
never really had to do this in this way
but we're returning all the money so
across the board we're putting out an
apology saying sorry about this Afro
Samurai - revenge of the koomer was
released as volume 1 in September for
the PlayStation 4 and PC with the Xbox
one release following in October two
additional chapters were planned to be
released later down the road with their
own unique stories combat systems and
characters with the game music being
produced by RZA of the wu-tang clan did
you buy Afro Samurai - what do you think
of it GameSpot's Peter Brown gave it a 2
out of 10 which is well it's not a great
score is it for more on all the latest
gaming gumption make sure to keep it
GameSpot calm